(soft music)
I belong to a very poor family.
At home - it's just a room - we live there.
My father is a car mechanic
and my mother is a housewife.
As a child, I used to fear mathematics.
Whenever I used to have
one question or one doubt,
I used to feel very shy asking teachers
because I heard that my friends
will laugh at me and stuff.
But then, Khan Academy videos are best
because I can play whenever I want,
how many times I wanted -
- so because of videos, my
concepts were crystal clear.
Now, I am able to teach
my fellow students.
I am in love with mathematics
just because of Khan Academy
and of course Khan Academy is best
because it is free of cost.
I also want to prove the world
and of course my village,
that having a girl child is not a problem.
Basically, I want to change the world
and education is the best way to do it.
So, I started with myself,
then of course my village
and then the whole world.